fatale available on premium video and on
demand today currently available in
theaters starring a friend of the
program mike coulter who was just
dynamite hillary swank and this actor
who also
is the pride of silver spring maryland
born in washington dc he's a terp
through and through and his washington
football team
is taking on the tampa bay buccaneers on
saturday night of super wild cardi
uh weekend the actor michael ealy here
on the rich asset show how are you
michael
i'm good rich how are you i am doing
fine so uh are you fired up for this
game on saturday night i i might imagine
michael yes
yes it's been a long time
it's it's been a long time um but yeah i
think uh
you know i think it it's to be
interesting to see what happens
um obviously the odds are stacked kind
of against us
but any given sunday right so did you go
to games in rfk in the old rfk
or or i did when i was little like when
i was little
you know my dad took me to a couple um
and i've only been to one game i think
at fedex field
uh because but you know by the time i
moved away from
from the area you know i just you know i
never got back on the sundays and time
for a game really
so who was your who was your guy growing
up then michael who are you like uh this
is this is the guy
i emulated you know uh sports fan who
was that guy
for you all right
art monk why not yeah one of the
all-time greats right
i mean one of the all-time great
all-time great it was like
you know he was he was you know he was
there
for the like the duration of my
childhood like
i love doug williams but he only gave us
a couple seasons right so right
you know what i mean like it's like you
talk about the tried and true guys the
mike nelms the john riggins
art monk gary clark
daryl green yeah daryl green green you
know
all those guys i grew up with and uh
they're all legends in
in my head you know daryl green you know
i run the 40-yard dash of the combine
every year for charity dow
green wants in he wants to beat me he
wants to prove that he could beat me i
think he might be
he's in his uh mid 50s and i want i want
no piece of him
michael you don't want that no i'm not
there for that smoke
he's 60. oh my god
yeah that dude looked like he was going
to be in shape his whole entire life
well the thing is even even at age 60 uh
his age his age would be my 40 time
6-0 like i would i would sign up for a
6-0 to run my 40 in a 6-0 i would sign
[Laughter]
i'd wait till daryl green's about 79
[Laughter]
by the way excellent advice let me write
that down michael they might write that
down
um okay so uh and then uh you're you're
a terp
right so uh who's your who's your who
was your guy
when you were at school there who was
who was going through the
maryland when you were well i was at
school joe smith
came nice like before i graduated
um ian and stevie francis
kind of came uh i think they were there
close to when i was there um
but yeah it was yeah it was i mean
uh blake and juan dixon came like
probably a little bit after me um but
you know when i was growing up len bias
was he was king
so yeah but i was actually i was this is
where it gets funny i was actually a
hoyas fan
okay before i went to maryland i was a
hoyas fan well i mean that's more
i guess if you really just want to talk
dc i mean that is washington dc
as he possibly can get and if you're
talking you must be talking about
what like allen iverson type georgetown
or
not without it
i mean that was patrick ewing michael
healey
i mean we got it so you're you're you
and i are the same age even though
um you know you're much more of a fine
wine than i am
um so um but so so we're talking about
the same era like you got to tell all
these tick tockers out there
that you know the big east which people
don't talk about
the big east of the 80s when ewing was
going through it
and mullen was my guy and st john's with
ra with raymond berry you know i mean uh
yeah oh not not raymond walderberg
walterberry of course
walter remember walter true barry the
truth right uh
of course it was and then and then
villanova won the national championship
demeanor right yeah and patino was
coaching
you know providence with the current
coach of the chicago bulls billy donovan
you know i mean like this is
serious business the big east back in
the day have you ever seen have you ever
seen a documentary requiem for the
biggie
i have i've heard i've never sat that
down but i need to see it i need to
watch it tremendous
do it it takes you back to that era and
i didn't even know this but technically
patrick ewing
the catalyst for the big east
to become what it was he was the first
big player to sign
with a vicious team and that created
what is now
well what was then you know labeled as
the big east like that's how they got
big it started with patrick ewing and
then it just kind of went from there
well i got to tell you man those were
those were the days no doubt about that
i'd love that so you're a georgetown fan
before
maryland terraplens michael ealy here on
the rich eisen show so let's talk about
your film here
um hilary swank my culture has been on
the show a couple times he's dynamite
and then you you're playing a successful
sports agent
and i'm wondering if you uh how you
studied for
this role in this film michael
yeah um well my sports agenting
is about one scene of this movie okay
it's about one scene of this movie and i
did a scene where i think we were like
me and mike were recruiting lance
stevenson because he was playing with
the lakers at the time
and we were recruiting him and uh you
know
it it wasn't that detailed because you
know like i said i i just didn't spend a
lot of time on that i spent most of the
movie
if not 99 of it kind of fighting for my
life
yes of the impact of hillary swank on me
on this one
right but yeah in terms of sports
changes
i i i kind of looked at uh
rich paul as kind of an example okay
and uh you know it was uh it's
interesting you know you build this
empire by yourself and you don't want to
kind of swallowed up on
by the behemoth that is william morris
and that was you know kind of the extent
of the
the aging agent dialogue so to school
but then there's the uh
as you said the 99 other of the film
i'll give you the floor on this and what
uh you enjoyed about it and what we will
enjoy about it seeing it and
apparently currently in theories and
available on premium video and on demand
today
yeah so you can it's in and you can take
it off now which is
much better obviously um it is um
it is a movie
seemingly having it all right you
imagine somebody who has it all they've
built this empire and
you know they got the wife they got the
house they got everything
and they're pretty broken
regardless of what's going on with him
personally and ultimately he goes to
vegas
and in vegas his his best friend and
business partner
played by mike coulter um you know
encouraged to just you know turn up and
you know that that leads to an
entanglement with
character and
i think everything is gonna that happens
unfortunately i think we're losing him
it does not
so we we come back to la and
um you know there's a there's a a
break-in at my house
and the investigator the head detective
on that happens to be
hilary swank's character and i'm sitting
there with my wife
so uh at that point
all hell breaks loose all hell breaks
loose and you watch this character
lose pretty much everything that he
worked so
hard for and thus the fatale part about
it so
that's available again on premium uh
video and on demand today
film currently uh available also in
theaters enjoy watching your washington
football team on saturday night i hope
they uh
they keep going it's a hell of a
feel-good story this year and um
and let's do this more often michael i
appreciate the call
i appreciate it rich thank you man
thanks for having me you got us michael
ealy
at michael early on twitter and at the
michael ealy on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here